[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so the idea behind any vaccine  is to introduce some piece of a virus to  your body  so you can mount an immune response and  then your immune system sees those  fragments and learns to respond to it  [Music]  you do things in parallel research  trials manufacturing and distribution  so if we think about how long we would  take to build our manufacturing network  typically that would be a two to three  year process we shrank it down to about  five months  [Music]  there are some important reasons why  messenger rna was appealing for  developing a covid19  vaccine first of all the virus itself  is an rna virus so it lent itself  to this technology  mrna-based vaccine you simply inject  the instruction set that teaches your  body how to make  a piece of the virus  [Music]  this is going to have a huge impact down  the road  [Music]  it's wonderful what's happening is an  extraordinary scientific breakthrough  [Music]  you